we begin with breaking news the irish
government and apple
have won their appeal against a 2016 eu
decision
that said apple had to pay the irish
government 13 billion euros
in back taxes money that ireland didn't
even want
so ireland took the case to europe's
second highest court
dublin has long denied that its tax
arrangements with apple amount to
illegal state aid
the european commission is expected to
appeal the ruling
to the european court of justice
early this year then irish prime
minister leo varadkar and apple chief
executive tim cook
had an anniversary to celebrate 40 years
since apple started manufacturing in
ireland
over the decades the eu country and the
us iphone maker have both profited from
the arrangement
apple gets a massive tax break but it
provides employment
from multinational companies the
favorable situation in ireland is
practically unrivaled in europe
at the moment firms officially pay 12.5
corporate tax in ireland that's compared
with the eu average of 21.3 percent
officially companies in germany have to
cough up at least 30 percent
that alone has attracted many companies
to ireland
and in fact apple paid far less tax at
times
for example as little as 0.005
in 2014 when the tech giant paid just 50
euros tax on every million euros in
profit
that was the last straw for eu
competition commissioner marguerite
vestaia
in 2016 the european commission ordered
apple to pay
ireland 13 billion euros in back taxes
but dublin and apple both appealed the
ruling
well i'm now joined by arthur sullivan
from dw business who's looked
a little bit closer to the story it
looks like a major
uh vindication for countries the low tax
uh policies
uh like ireland so where does this leave
the european commission in their fight
against tax avoidance
well it's definitely a blow guard
symbolically it's a big blow but it is
important to draw a distinction between
this specific case and the wider fight
against tax avoidance so this case
looked at the issue of illegal state aid
did apple's specific arrangements in
ireland amount to illegal state aid
the courts today said it didn't that the
commission did not prove that it did
on on various levels and the the verdict
is quite clear in that regard
however the wider issue that is that
countries like ireland and the
netherlands and so on so forth
that the commission increasingly has
been looking the the competition
commissioner
margaret vestar has been increasingly
looking to tackle this issue
and we're here seeing more and more
reports that the
uh the commission are increasingly
willing to use tools they've never used
before
such as bringing in voting on changing
the corporate tax structures in the eu
not by totally uh all 27 members
agreeing but by a qualified majority now
if that comes in
that would mean that the fight is still
very much on but how
does this ruling how will this go down
uh
across capitals indeed depends on what
capitals you're talking about in places
like dublin the hague i suspect that
it'll be going down very well
places like paris and berlin much less
so and the big
backdrop of all this of course is that
this week european leaders are meeting
to discuss the pandemic recovery fund
so they're asking the leaders of
countries and governments to give
unprecedented sums of money that will be
given as grants
that they've never done before while at
the same time they're seeing a court
ruling today that grants companies like
apple
a fortune and the figures that we saw
like where they paid
0.000 tax so
obviously that is a very very difficult
backdrop to argue on one level you're
telling
the leaders of certain countries we need
your money while apple is
merely taking its money to who knows
where so
obviously it's a very very difficult
context so certainly there will be a
challenging reaction and i have no doubt
it will come up at the talks that are
happening this week
so is this the end of the affair no
certainly not the european commission
although it hasn't confirmed this yet
but it would be a shock if they weren't
going to appeal this to the highest
court
the european court of justice and if
that happens we'll be waiting for
another two years we could be back here
in two years time talking about this
gerhard
and the overall fight against tax
avoidance in in europe and and the world
as a whole
one that the oecd is involved in that's
not going anywhere the waters are rising
on this issue it's a blow to the
commission in their fight a significant
blow but this is not over
arthur sullivan thank you very much
you